.
>> YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE NEW
SEASON OF THE GROUP CHAT LIVE AT
BLEACHER REPORT.
I AM GREG IVORY.
ERIN, ARE YOU READY FOR NBA TO
BE BACK?
>> YES.
I AM SO EXCITED FOR NBA TO BE
BACK.
I AM SO EXCITED TO BE ON MY
SECOND SEASON OF THE GROUP CHAT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
>> WE ARE GIVING AWAY HOODIES
AND JERSEYS.
THE FIRST ONE IS GOING OUT NOW.
I AM ABOUT TO HOOK SOMEONE UP IN
THE CHAT WITH $125 TO BUY
WHATEVER JERSEY THEY WANT.
I HAVE THE HANDY DANDY PHONE.
THIS RIGHT HERE IS HOW YOU ARE
GO TO GET YOUR HOODIE AND
JERSEYS.
SO LET ME TAP IN.
I SEE SAMMY.
SAMMY94 SAYS 37 POINTS.
HE WILL SCORE 37.
LeBRON.
SAYING LeBRON WILL SCORE 37.
I HAVE ONE MORE.
LeBRON IS GOING TO SCORE 30
POINTS.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
JERSEY GIFT CARD.
I AM NOT ONLY HOOKING ONE PERSON
UP.
FANDUEL IS PLUGGING EVERYBODY.
TELL THEM WHAT'S THE DIAGONAL.
>> IN HONOR OF THE NBA'S 75th
SEASON, FANDUEL IS GIVING 75/1
ODDS ON ANY ONE TEAM TO WIN THE
FIRST GAME TODAY OR TOMORROW.
A CHANCE TO WIN UP TO $150.
>> YOU CAN DEFINITELY PLACE A
LOT OF BETS WITH THAT MONEY.
THE QUESTION IS, WILL THERE BE
TWO THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME?
THAT IS WHAT THE 3 X 2 IS.
WE ASKED WHICH WILL CASH THE
NIGHT, MILWAUKEE AND BROOKLYN OR
THE WARRIORS TAKING ON THE
LAKERS?
THE WARRIORS ARE IN FRONT AT
62%.
WHICH IS A LOCK TONIGHT.
I NEED GIFS AND EMOJIS AND
WINNERS ONLY PLEASE.
ERIN, TALK TO US.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THE 3 X 2
TONIGHT?
>> I LOVE THAT WE BROUGHT IT
BACK.
THE NETS AND BUCKS.
HAVE YOU SEEN GIANNIS DRAIN
THOSE THREES?
I FOUND ONE STAT THAT WAS KIND
OF INTERESTING IN TERMS OF 3 X
2.
THE LEAGUE WIDE THREE-POINT RATE
INCREASED UP TO 39% LAST SEASON
AND INCREASED MORE IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THAN IT DID IN THE
PREVIOUS FIVE.
LAST SEASON, 28 OUT OF THE 30
TEAMS TOOK AT LEAST A THIRD OF
THE SHOTS FROM THREE-POINT
RANGE.
I AM RIDING WITH THE NETS AND
THE BUCKS.
GREG, I HAVE SEEN YOU ROCKING
WITH YOUR OWN FAVORITE TEAM?
>> YOU ALREADY KNOW THE TEAM.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL.
BEFORE I GET INTO MY TAKE, LET
ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
ENDERMAN HAS STEPH CURRY AS A
GIF.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
CHRISJ2173 SAYS WARRIORS/LAKERS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU CHRISJ.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
BRANDON SAYS WARRIORS/LAKERS
WILL WIN THAT.
ERIN, I HAVE TO MAKE MY
DECISION.
I AM A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
I READ THREE COMMENTS LEANING
TOWARDS THE GOLDEN STATE/LAKERS
GAME.
IT IS PLUS MONEY.
I MEAN COME ON.
I AM RIDING WITH THE GUYS.
RIDING WITH THE WARRIORS.
RIDING WITH THE LAKERS.
SHOOTERS ALL OVER THE COURT.
LAKERS HAVE A TEAM FULL OF HALL
OF FAMERS.
WARRIORS PUT UP SHOTS.
THIS YEAR THEY WILL PUT UP THE
MOST THREES IN FRANCHISE HISTORY
THIS YEAR.
HERE WE GO.
I BELIEVE WE ARE RIDING AS A
FAMILY, ERIN.
THE PRODUCER TOLD ME IN MY EAR
WE ARE RIDING AS A FAMILY WITH
THE WARRIORS AND THE LAKERS.
3 X 2.
I WILL BE AT THE GAME TONIGHT
WITH MY NAME META ARTEST.
TAP IN TO THE IG STORY WHERE YOU
GUYS ARE.
WE HAVE TO GO TO ONE OF THESE
GAMES THESE DAYS.
>> I KNOW.
>> LET'S DO A SHOW AT ONE OF
THOSE GAMES.
MOVING ON, ERIN, HOW MANY POINTS
WILL LeBRON JAMES SCORE?
WE ASKED YOU HOW MANY LeBRON
WILL SCORE TONIGHT AGAINST THE
WARRIORS.
THERE IT IS.
TELL ME HOW MANY POINTS LeBRON
IS PUTTING UP.
AT THE END OF THE GAME WE WILL
DM ONE PERSON THAT GUESSED
CLOSEST AND HOOK YOU UP WHERE A
JERSEY.
LeBRON IS SITTING AT 23 1/2
POINTS.
THE LINE IS MOVING UP AND DOWN.
DO YOU LIKE THAT NUMBER?
>> SO, LeBRON AVERAGED 25 POINTS
PER GAME LAST SEASON.
WITH THIS NUMBER SET AT 23 1/2.
IT KEEPS COMING DOWN.
YESTERDAY, 24 1/2.
HE WILL BE DISTRIBUTING THE BALL
AND I AM GOING TO SEE HOW THE
BIG THREE PLAYS TOGETHER.
HE DID HIT OVER THE NUMBER THE
LAST GAME IN A LOSS TO THE
KINGS.
AGAINST THE WARRIORS, AND IT IS
A REGULAR SEASON GAME AND
OPENING NIGHT, I THINK IT WOULD
BE DIFFERENT.
UNFORTUNATELY I AM GOING WITH
THE UNDER.
I KNOW YOU DON'T FEEL THE SAME.
>> WELL, ERIN, BEFORE I HOP INTO
IT, I HAVE TO TALK TO THE
PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE CAN PROBABLY PERSUADE
PEA TO GO THE OTHER WAY.
LeBRON IS GOING FOR 33 TONIGHT.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I AM MOVING ON.
I SEE AARONCOOL IS IN THE
COMMENTS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
I WANT TO BE AS COOL AS YOU.
HE SAID LeBRON IS GOING FOR 31.
>> OKAY.
>> ONCE AGAIN, ROCKING WITH THE
OVER.
ERIN, I HAVE ONE MORE HOODIE IN
ME.
I SEE RYAN RAY.
HE SAYS 25.
ERIN, UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS THE
OVER.
I AM RIDING WITH THE FANS.
I AM RIDING WITH THE PEOPLE IN
THE COMMENTS.
I AM GOING TO LEAN LeBRON JAMES
OVER HERE.
THERE ARE NO HARD FEELINGS.
>> NONE TAKEN.
>> I FEEL LIKE LeBRON IS GOING
TO COME OUT TONIGHT AND TRY TO
PUT THE BALL IN THE BASKET.
THEY HAVE RUSS, LeBRON, RONDO.
WE KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO
FACILITATE, BUT THEY NEED PEOPLE
TO PUT THE BALL IN THE BASKET
AND I FEEL LIKE PEOPLE KNOWS
THAT.
LeBRON IS GOING TO COME OUT
AGGRESSIVE, BUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN THEY ARE GOING TO WIN.
REMEMBER, WE ARE GOING TO HIT
ONE OF THE GUYS UP AFTER THE
GAME AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A
JERSEY.
I HAVE MORE JERSEYS TO GIVE AWAY
RIGHT NOW.
WARRIORS/LAKERS, NETS/BUCKS WHO
ARE KICKING OFF THE SEASON WITH
THE REMATCH OF LAST YEAR'S
EASTERN CONFERENCE SEMIFINALS
WHICH I DON'T NEED TO REMIND YOU
WAS A SEVEN-GAME BATTLE.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS SCORING MORE
POINTS.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> I THINK K.D. WILL HAVE MORE
POINTS.
WE KNOW IT IS A REVENGE GAME.
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE BALL,
GIANNIS, 40 POINTS PER GAME ON
60% OR BETTER IN EACH OF THE
LAST THREE SEASONS.
>> ERIN IS ROCKING WITH K.D.
K.D. 30.
HE HAS A K.D.GIF OF HIM JUMPING
AROUND.
I GOT J23.
GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO FOR SURE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU I THINK K.D.
WILL COME BACK TODAY.
AND HE HAS A CHIP ON HIS
SHOULDER.
THE NETS WENT INTO THE PLAYOFFS
BEAT UP.
YOU KNOW, THIS BUCKS TEAM ENDED
UP BEATING THE NETS TEAM.
I THINK K.D. WILL COME BACK WITH
A VENGEANCE AND CHIP ON HIS
SHOULDER AND MIGHT GO FOR 50.
HE MIGHT GO FOR 50.
HE MIGHT.
IT IS K.D.
>> NOTHING SURPRISES ME WITH
K.D.
>> YEAH.
IT IS KEVIN DURANT.
LIKE YOU SAID, YOU KNOW WHO I
AM.
WE KNOW WHO HE IS.
HE IS KEVIN DURANT.
WE TALK TONIGHT'S GAME.
NOW LET'S TALK FUTURES.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO DO YOU THINK
IS WINNING IT ALL.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
DROP YOUR LOCKS.
I AM GOING TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY
TO MY FAVORITE TAKE.
ERIN, TELL ME WHAT YOU SEE.
>> THE BROOKLYN NETS ARE THE
FAVORITE PLUS 250.
LAKERS PLUS 400.
TOP FIVE TEAMS I WANTED TO
MENTION.
NETS/LAKERS.
YOUR WARRIORS.
BULLS.
THIS MARKET I AM GOING TO GO
WITH THE LONG SHOT.
I LIKE THE MIAMI HEAT.
25/1.
I KNOW THEY WERE SWEPT BY THE
BUCKS IN THE PLAYOFFS.
KYLE LOWRY, BAM ADEBAYO, GO WITH
THE LONG SHOT IN THIS ONE.
I LIKE THEM TO COME OUT OF THE
EAST.
>> OKAY.
ERIN DROPPED HER PICK.
I HAVE TO KNOW, ARE YOU
SPRINKLING MONEY ON YOUR SIXERS
THIS YEAR?
>> SPRINKLING I FEEL WILL BE
MORE VODKA INTO MY DRINK THE
MORE I HEAR ABOUT BEN SIMMONS
AND HIS DRAMA.
THE MAN GOT KICKED OUT OF
PRACTICE TODAY FOR HIS POOR
ATTITUDE AND I THINK IT WILL
AFFECT THE CHEMISTRY ON THE TEAM
AND I WILL NOT BE SPRINKLING ANY
MONEY ON THE SIXERS UNTIL I SEE
THEM PLAY WITHOUT BEN ON THE
FLOOR.
>> ERIN IS NOT A FAN OF BEN
SIMMONS.
>> THAT IS NOT --
>> IT IS NOT A FAN.
THAT IS OKAY.
I AM A FAN OF GIVING YOU GUYS
HOODIES.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS READING
YOUR GUYS TAKES.
I HAVE BRBETTING IS IN THE
COMMENTS.
I HAVE SNOOPY2153 SAYS CELTICS.
CELTICS.
CELTICS AFTER BIG MIDSEASON
ACQUISITIONS, A LOT OF FIRE
EMOJI.
I LIKE THE CURVE THERE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I AM GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
IF YOU HEAR A COMMENT THAT IS
JERSEY WORTH.
LOW THE BRAKES.
I AM A DUBS FAN.
THAT IS A BIT AGGRESSIVE.
I AM STILL IN THE COMMENTS.
I HAVE JULIO HERNANDEZ.
WHEN YOU HAVE LeBRON, IT IS
GOING TO BE TOUGH TO OVERCOME
ALL OF THOSE PIECES.
THAT IS A BIG QUESTION.
IN FACT I FEEL LIKE JULIO.
HE WROTE TO BOTH OF US.
HE GAVE US A DETAILED TAKE.
JULIO, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
THE JERSEY, BROTHER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
ERIN, LET'S MOVE ON AND TALK
MVP.
LET'S TALK MVP.
>> WHAT DO YOU SEE.
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
ANYTHING CATCHES YOUR EYE?
>> LUKA BEING THE MOST BET ON
PLAYER IN THE MARKET STICKS OUT
TO ME.
THE LAST THREE TO WIN MVP WERE
HARDEN, WESTBROOK AND CURRY.
YOU CAN TAKE A LONG SHOT.
SO MANY THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
>> YES.
YES.
>> YEAH.
WHO ARE YOU GOING TO RIDE WITH?
>> I THINK I AM GOING WITH
DAMIAN LILLARD, 12/1.
HE AVERAGED 29 POINTS LAST
SEASON.
HE IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST PIECES
OF THE TEAM.
THERE IS A CASE YOU CAN MAKE FOR
GIANNIS.
REIGNING FINALS MVP.
AVERAGED 28 OVER THE LAST THREE
SEASONS AND NOW IS WORKING ON
THE JUMPER.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT K.D. BUT
TAKING THE LONG SHOT.
>> ERIN IS ROCKING WITH LILLARD.
NO GIANNIS.
NO DONCIC.
THIS MIGHT BE EMBIID'S YEAR.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A H
D
HOO
HOODIE.
LeBRON MVP.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
THIS CAUGHT MY ATTENTION.
NOAH J. RODRIGUEZ.
CURRY GOING CRAZY THIS SEASON.
LOCK.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU NOAH.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
YES.
STEPH CURRY SHOULD HAVE WON THE
MVP LAST YEAR.
THE WARRIORS GOT BETTER THIS
YEAR.
KLAY IS COMING BACK.
>> ESPECIALLY WITH THE SCORING
TITLES.
IF HE GOES OFF AND HAS AN
UNBELIEVABLE SEASON.
PRESEASON HE WAS LOOKING INSANE.
SOME OF THE KPLCLIPS THAT I SAW.
>> I LOVE THAT.
I THINK STEPH CURRY SHOULD HAVE
WON THE MVP BUT THEY SCRATCHED
THEIR WAY TO THE EIGHTH SEED AND
DIDN'T MAKE THE PLAYOFFS.
THIS YEAR WILL BE A DIFFERENT
STORY.
I AM ROCKING WITH STEPH CURRY TO
WIN THE MVP.
GAVE OUT HOODIES ALREADY.
I MIGHT WANT TO GIVE OUT ANOTHER
ONE.
LET'S TALK ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
LAMELO WAS THE FAVORITE LAST
YEAR.
THIS YEAR THE FAVORITE IS JALEN
GREEN.
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
>> 4 OF THE LAST 10 WINNERS WERE
THE OVERALL FIRST PICK.
JALEN GREEN IS THE FAVORITE.
THERE IS GOOD VALUE IN SOME OF
THE OTHER GUYS.
EVAN MOBLEY UP THERE.
>> IT IS A GOOD MARKET.
ARE YOU RIDING WITH THE FAVORITE
OR ARE YOU PICKING A DOG?
>> I AM GOING TO GO WITH THE
LONG SHOT, JALEN SUGGS.
HE WILL BE ABLE TO HELP ORLANDO
WHO HAS LIMITED DEPTH.
HARD TO BANK ON AN MVP.
HE HAS TO STAY HEALTHY AND IS ON
A NEW TEAM.
THEY ARE COMING FROM COLLEGE.
GO WITH THE LONG SHOT IN THIS.
>> SUGGS IS A GOOD PICK.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HE DOES WITH
THE ORLANDO TEAM.
I HAD A CHANCE TO WATCH A LOT OF
THE GUYS PLAYING IN THE SUMMER
LEAGUE.
I DID.
NO ONE IMPRESSED ME LIKE DAVION
MITCHELL AND LED THEM TO THE
SUMMER LEAGUE CHAMPIONSHIP.
HE HIT HIS THREES.
I CAN SEE THAT TRANSLATING INTO
HIS GAME ON THE SACRAMENTO KINGS
TEAM THIS YEAR.
AND SO I AM GOING WITH A LONG
SHOT HERE.
I AM GOING WITH A LONG SHOT AND
MY OWN EYE TEST.
MITCHELL WILL WIN THE ROOKIE OF
THE YEAR THIS YEAR BUT WE ARE
NOT DONE.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I HAVE TO SEE WHO THE PEOPLE ARE
RIDING WITH.
CUNNINGHAM.
GREEN.
GREEN SLEEPER CELL.
>> MAYBE HE HAS INSIDE
INFORMATION.
>> YOU KNOW, WE GET AROUND.
WE GET AROUND.
WE HAVE BEEN ON THE ROAD THIS
SUMMER.
I HAVE MY OWN EYE TEST.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
REGULAR SEASON.
YOU ARE GETTING LOVE IN THE
COMMENTS.
AARON GOT IT RIGHT.
IT IS SUGGS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
>> GIVE HIM A HOODIE.
>> OF COURSE.
HE IS WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> I GOT ONE MORE.
RYAN RAY SAYS CADE CUNNINGHAM.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY.
ONE MORE JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY.
IT IS TIME FOR THE LAST SEGMENT.
YOU KNOW IT WOULD NOT BE A GROUP
CHAT IF I DID NOT COOK UP SAME
GAME PARLAY.
BEFORE I KICK IT OFF FANDUEL HAS
SOMETHING SPECIAL FOR THOSE OF
YOU THAT LIKE TO SPRINKLE ON THE
SAME GAME PARLAY.
TELL THE WORLD WHAT IS UP.
>> ONE RISK-FREE SAME GAME
PARLAY TO BE USED TUESDAY,
WEDNESDAY, THURSDAY.
EITHER WAY IT IS RISK-FREE.
YOU CAN CHECK OUT YOUR ACCOUNTS
TO USE ON THE FIRST THREE DAYS
OF THE SEASON.
LET'S HEAR THE SAME GAME PARLAY.
>> BEFORE I GET MY PARLAY WHAT I
NEED EVERYBODY TO DO IS TELL ME
WHAT YOU THINK OF MY PICKS IN
THE COMMENTS.
WE ARE STARTING IT OFF.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT EARLIER IN
THE SHOW.
WE TALKED ABOUT LeBRON'S POINT
TOTAL.
I SAID HE WAS GOING OVER AND I
AM CONTINUING TO SAY HE IS GOING
OVER.
25 PLUS.
WHO IS GOING TO PUT THE BALL IN
THE BUCKET AND I THINK LeBRON
JAMES WILL BE ONE OF THOSE.
AND WE ARE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
FIRST QUARTER TOTAL.
IT IS SITTING AT 57 1/2.
WE ARE GOING UNDER HERE.
THE LAKERS ARE HISTORICALLY
KNOWN AS A SLOW STARTING TEAM I
FEEL LIKE THE TREND WILL
CONTINUE IN TODAY'S GAME AND WE
ARE GOING UNDER 57 1/2 FOR THE
FIRST QUARTER TOTAL.
MOVING ON TO ANOTHER FUTURE HALL
OF FAMER ON THE LAKERS TEAM,
RUSSELL WESTBROOK.
NO, I AM NOT GOING TO GO TO HIS
ASSIST TOTALS BUT TALK ABOUT HIM
PUTTING THE BALL IN THE BASKET.
USUALLY HE TRIES TO ROCK THE
BABY AGAINST STEPH CURRY.
I THINK THAT IS A MISMATCH.
I THINK THAT WILL CONTINUE AND
HE WILL GO OVER 17 1/2 POINTS.
I THINK HE WILL GO OVER 17 1/2.
I THINK RUSS WILL LOOK TO SCORE
A LOT IN TODAY'S GAME.
MOVING ON TO STEPH CURRY.
MOVING ON.
I AM NOT GOING TO POINTS TOTAL
BUT ASSIST NUMBERS.
I AM GOING TO GO FOUR PLUS
ASSISTS.
LOOK FOR YOUR SHOOTERS STEPH.
THE WARRIORS ADDED TO THE TEAM.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, DRAYMOND
GREEN.
BIG DRAYMOND.
I AM GOING OVER SEVEN AND A
HALF.
THE WARRIORS HAVE STEPH CURRY.
AND WE HAVE GOTTEN BETTER AROUND
THE PERIMETER SHOOTING THE
THREE.
FIND THE OTHER SHOOTERS.
GIVE ME 7 1/2 ASSIST S.
>> THAT IS A GOOD PAY OUT.
>> PULL UP THE ODDS.
>> JAMES GOING OVER IN POINTS
AND THE SAME WITH WESTBROOK.
OTHER THAN THAT I REALLY LIKE
IT.
IT IS A GOOD ONE.
>> CAN WE GO SEE.
WE WILL SEE.
IT GIVES YOU $2,057 IF YOU YOU
PUT $100 ON IT.
LET ME SEE WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT IN THE COMMENTS ABOUT MY
PARLAY.
LANDON IS BACK.
YOUR BOY LANDON IS BACK IN THE
COMMENTS.
JESSE SAY S LIKE HUNGRY THAT MV
HE IS GOING TO EAT THIS YEAR.
GIVING OUT MORE HOODIES.
DAMIAN LILLARD SAY SLEEPER.
MICAH SAYS WE ARE RIDING WITH
GREG.
ENDERMAN.
G-MONEY ALWAYS GOT THE BEST
PARLAYS.
EVERYBODY THERE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
I HAVE TO GIVE OUT A JERSEY
HERE.
I AM LOOKING FOR A GOOD TAKE.
ERIC McCALL SAYS I THINK LeBRON
JAMES SCORES LESS THAN 25
BECAUSE WESTBROOK LOOKS TO SCORE
ON CURRY FIRST QUARTER UNDER THE
SAME REASON YOU SAID CURRY
ASSISTS GOOD.
I GOT KIND OF CONFUSED WITH THE
COMMENT AT THE END.
BUT THAT IS OKAY.
WE UNDERSTOOD THE TAKE.
LeBRON JAMES IS GOING LESS THAN
25.
THAT IS WHAT YOU SAID, ERIN.
UNDER 23 1/2.
ERIC McCALL, I AM GOING TO HOOK
YOU UP WITH A JERSEY.
I THINK IT IS TIME TO TAKE IT ON
HOME.
THANK YOU FOR TAPPING IN TO THE
GROUP CHAT.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS AND
THE LAKERS 3 X 2 IS A LOCK.
LeBRON MIGHT HAVE A GOOD GAME
BUT GOLDEN STATE WILL BE READY.
K.D. IS PUTTING UP MORE POINTS
THAN GIANNIS.
AND WE WILL BE BACK NEXT WEEK
GIVING OUT MORE HOODIES, JERSEYS
AND LOCKS AND IF YOU WANT A
HOODIE TODAY WE WILL D.M. YOU.
I WON'T.
ERIN WON'T.
B.R. BETTING WILL REACH OUT AND
D.M. YOU AND YOU KNOW WHAT, I AM
GOING TO GIVE OUT A HOODIE FOR
FUN.
I HAVE GOT TWO COMMENTERS.
I WANT YOU TO LET ME KNOW WHO I
SHOULD GIVE IT TO.
GREG QUINN SAYS WESTBROOK MIGHT
NOT GET THE OVER SINCE HE IS A
PASSER AND LOOKS TO GET GUYS
OPEN.
HE IS REFERRING TO ME TALKING
ABOUT HIS POINT TOTALS OVER 17
1/2.
GREG QUINN WITH THAT TAKE AND
J23 SAYS WESTBROOK, JAMES, MELO
GOING OFF.
LeBRON JAMES 34 POINTS WITH A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
FIRST ONE.
I DON'T THINK ALL THREE GO OFF.
>> SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YES.
YOU HAVE TO JUST PICK ONE OF
THEM.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
GET ON FANDUEL.
RIDE WITH US.
WE ARE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.
>> SEE YA.
♪ ♪